je pense que le meilleur coût de Stephen
Harper a été son leadership
économique la crise mondial de 2008 2009
a
été le Canada s'en est très bien tiré de
sorte que les banques sont tous intacts
on a aussi signé plusieurs traités de
libre échange la baisse à tps de 7 à 5 %
et CEA je pense que le leadership
économique de monsieur Harper a été
vraiment extraordinaire de l'utre côté
si on pense à des mauvais coupts si on
veut c'est pas vraiment des mauvais
coups je pense que c'est une opportunité
raté c'est on a Monsieur harp a
maintenant un gouvernement majoritaire
mais sans grande représentation du
Québec je pense que ça augmente le
clivage entre le Québec et le reste du
Canada et ça je trouve ça vraiment
dommage donc c'est une opportunité qui a
été ratée en 2008 et si je
pense cette réputation canadienne je
veux plutôt mettre mon chapeau albertin
je pense que mon image de l'Alberta l'
International c'est un peuple avec un
sens de
l'entrepreneurship de résilience et de
service à la communauté qui est
absolument hors du commun ici en
Alberta